howdy has rolled out a facelifted
version of its a7 as auto pundits
expected the body's nips and tucks are
barely noticeable
the sedans roof contours are unchanged
the rear was only slightly touched up
the real work has gone into the engines
emotive and politics
car Testament as Kurata explains that
the engine range has been thoroughly
overhauled in some cases newly developed
the 3 liter turbo diesel is outies
best-selling engine in Germany and now
it's available in four power ratings
he's taking the strongest one out
available only in the special
competition model the competition models
3 liter TDI slams out a spanking 650
Newton meters of torque with 240
kilowatts of power achieving an
acceleration of 0 to 100 km/h and 5.1
seconds the rated fuel consumption
specifies 6.1 litres of diesel per 100
kilometers Montes mentions that at the
other end of the 3 liter TDI spectrum is
the fuel saving a7 ultra the ultra is a
few kilograms lighter than the normal a7
it's 160 kilowatts of power might sound
less than impressive but it'll spread
from zero to one hundred and seven point
three seconds while dropping the rated
consumption down to 4.7 liters the ultra
models start at around 55 thousand euros
in Germany
in point resistance esteem Montez lists
the driver assistances the a7 boasts an
active Lane Assist
a presense plus collision warning system
and a site assist blind spot warning
light in the mirror that tells you when
someone is tailgating your car
the a7 also sports a parking system plus
and a night vision assistant that even
works during the day it shows the street
on coming and passing vehicles and
pedestrians in the display clearly and
distinctly as eyeless Letizia clown
tightly hand inside the interior gives
the high-quality impression typical of
Audi all the controls and materials feel
right a separate climate control for the
rear seats adds an extra touch of class
though taller passengers might be
advised to sit in front
Montez confirms that the seats are
comfortable enough for long hauls and
that the back is a bit low for taller
occupants including Corp among course
covetousness the company now called OD
has been making cars for over a century
this year it celebrated the 25th
birthday of the turbo diesel or the TDI
is all this experience noticeable and
the a7 Montes admits that the facelifted
a7 is yet another Audi that's above any
real criticism which he very much
regrets since he so enjoys raking
expensive cars over the coals
but of course such a beautiful car costs
a pretty penny a smart design lots of
driver assists a powerful TDI and
comfort that won't quit
the competition is indeed serious
competition in the midsize luxury car
segment and Germany this special model
starts at seventy two thousand four
hundred euros